y sobre una narración en lareonion de la
controles deslizantes de América del Sur y Brasil e
su problema Dios si preguntan
porlas sorpresa
declara de acquedol con el escudo de armas que
se discutió en el parma kumble
declaraciones
en comparación con el entorno de la institución
democracia y quién la llevó a cabo
derecho deopinare sobrielo que le digo
must Venezuela lakage pua gregola
Bienne que el operior que si fuera y
sintetata aparece el sol con elvedo
sobre el tema de Rovereto en manos E en
Venezuela y no estuvo deprimida entre los
ravion con los de mas pilates y el
el chileno gabriel boris yo digo que es
tema es real grave il serio y en
Venezuela Y quien es Emocionante responde Clara
películas
paracalosererecioso humano eres
se respeta y salen pais y la chilena
celebró el retiro de Venezuela tiene la
institución multilateral por alerta
cuales son los de servir
seaga la vista agorda a los problemas
Eso
pregunta relacional
fue invitado siempre que fuera líder de la
país de la Región le digo que
ubores y en y dentro del límite de
la democracia y el presidente brasileño
yo digo
Está obligando a protagonizar un acuerdo con
Nadia la recomiendo me encanta
narrativa propia